um boiler Oh Lord oh Lord one bleep $5
on twisted or oh that's you Oh John is
drum rolling today welcome to et at the
movies everybody I'm so excited for the
one today I'm ash Crossan I'm John boon
and we are talking about a good movie
hey good movie
I'm thinking it's breaking the vce you
curse I am saying if Suicide Squad was a
step in the right direction which I
still stick by the fact that it was that
movie is a hot-ass mess no I feel sorry
good but it is at least more
entertaining than Batman vs Superman but
the best part of Batman vs Superman was
what one of them good movie step in the
right direction
the best DC movie in their current verse
good star heads down by far and stuff
doesn't count but yeah Wow
was your ultimate takeaway from the
movie my ultimate takeaway was that
there's color it's colorful and there's
pretty things to look at and the entire
time they're on the island of the
amazonian there's saturation and ocean
it's paradise it's perfect bring me
there it's the Instagram culture that DC
meet is the gal gadot seems like she is
Wonder Woman every time she was on the
shoot I tweeted us earlier there could
have been a bunch of like you want to
plug your Twitter handle over here as
Crossan at me please there could have
been a bunch of like monkeys and
penguins wearing top hats and suits in
the background and I wouldn't have
noticed because every time gal gadot was
on screen she commanded it in such a way
that I was only focused on her I am
gonna say kind of a hot take because
everybody's like loved Christine and I
didn't until this movie this is the most
chemistry I've ever seen him have with
another actor or actress I don't know
what was different but it was unmatched
from anybody else I've ever seen him
work with look at that a white dude
named Chris is not the lead of a
superhero movie and it's cool he's like
great at playing second fiddle to her
he's charming and nude what didn't you
like about one of them what is so
disappointing about Wonder Woman is it
starts off so promising and it's so good
and action scenes are really crit and
they're cool and they're colorful and
like I'm into it I'm buying it and then
you get to the end and it's the usual DC
flashing light CGI superhero suit that
with indistinguishable Smashing and
and who even the hell knows what's
happening anymore there's a plot to us
at the end that's so like contrived and
unnecessary and amid all the like other
parts of the finale that I didn't love I
was just like this is leaving me with a
bit of a sour case went again it's a
good movie
welcome to jolly old London Pete here
yeah that's not for everybody I did feel
like I was like I get it gal gadot it's
like Wonder Woman Diana she's gorgeous
right but otherwise does everybody need
to point it out like I was almost like
God stop objectifying her like a cousin
20 yeah I totally agree with you
she's pretty we get it but yeah every
single person in the movie eight oh
there's you and we can talk about what's
really important about this movie is
that it's a success it's a hopefully to
be a successful
it'll be female lead superhero film and
dirty no lead directed by a female I
don't think it was written by a female
but it will get there if we talk about
the other female maybe if it had been
written by a female they would imagine
say she was pretty at everything and I
do believe this was the first superhero
directed movie since Punisher warzone I
like the Alexander which was a hero
directed well yeah sorry honey just
directed super no but yes patty Jenkins
is a superhero she saved the DC
Cinematic exactly Brava
I hope that patty Jenkins has a bigger
voice in this universe going forward she
brings fun to it she brings color to it
she brings new ideas to it that honestly
we haven't been seeing with the other
movies that have come out it's hard in
the ever-present battle between Marvel
and DC I'm not trying to start a flame
war Marvel's movies work you pretty much
even when they don't work it's not that
bad but the bigger picture is that they
work you're going to get a pretty good
movie from them do you see it feels like
every movie everything's riding on it if
this one hadn't worked would we just
keep suffering you through them and now
it's like this one works but it's not
even like yes it's working let's go
it's like would even come to next well
we can Justice League it gets like god I
hope that one works that's my flame war
ran
for the day yeah good luck I'm not
trying to start anything Marvel doesn't
pay me their last check didn't even
clear I'm just wondering when it's going
to switch from being very excited about
Marvel movies and hesitantly worried
about DC movies to excited about both
but enough about what I love about
Marvel let's go back to Wonder Woman and
she's going to be in at least two more
movies Justice League
Justice League this week do and
hopefully I wonder fail maybe up her her
role a little bit going for just because
she was my favorite part of Batman for
Superman and I feel like I want to see
her more on screen I'm also hoping that
though like I think they are slate is
pretty built out through like 2092
I don't know how long far are we
planning these movies ahead I mean it's
like 2100 yeah so it's blocked out
forever but I hope they this movie does
gangbusters that's a term no one uses
anymore but it's like like really well I
hope this movie does gangbusters and
they slip in a Wonder Woman to in the in
the slate you know I certainly will take
a Wonder Woman to before I need any more
Superman movies I don't need the dark
and gritty of all those dudes anymore
I'm like give me more Wonder Woman
please go see Wonder Woman we loved it
so much skin theaters Friday yeah
everyone hates I'll do the sign off this
week you sing the song okay did it thank
you for tuning into et at the movies ah
like subscribe do all that stuff I'm
seeing how long I can talk to see how
long she can do this song anyway see you
next week bye hi
you
[Music]